this video is sponsored by
curiositystream and nebula and will be a
little bit different for reasons i'll
address at the end
perhaps more than most people i spend a
fair bit of time thinking about climate
change it's a subject that i've made
more than a few videos about making
videos about climate change isn't easy
partly of course because of the
scientific and societal complexity but
also because it's so relentlessly
negative talking time and time again
about the nature of the problem how
scientists have understood it in
increasing clarity for decades and how
still not enough is being done to
address it and the increasingly dire
consequences of that inaction many
people look at how society is responding
to climate change and fall into despair
or dumerism but i'm not one of them i
fully expect there are many people in
the comments section who disagree with
me there always are and along with that
continue but i don't feel hopeless when
i look at climate change that's not to
say that i feel hopeful
but i find there are reasons to not
despair so in this video i'd like to
share them with you maybe they'll keep
hope for the future alive in you too
firstly the fact that climate change is
a cumulative problem the more fossil
fuels we burn the more carbon we extract
from the earth's crust and put into its
atmosphere where it stays on human time
scales anyway the more carbon that
builds up there the more energy is
trapped in the earth system and the
warmer the planet gets on average we
have already caused warming that cannot
be undone and the more carbon we add in
the future the warmer we will get but
look at it from a different perspective
there is literally no point at which
reducing emissions of carbon will not
make a positive difference we can always
stop making the problem worse yes there
are feedback cycles in the atmosphere
including some that are irreversible on
human time scales that could take a
small forcing from human emissions and
make a much larger impact rendering
small reductions in emissions pointless
but i've seen nothing in the literature
that convinces me we have passed or will
likely pass a threshold whereby runaway
warming is inevitable
so
any action taken to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions will make the future
better
while we have already caused a certain
level of warming and are committed to a
level more
i see any action we take as a win even
if that action is too slow to prevent
one and a half or two degrees of warming
this century it will still help avoid
the truly apocalyptic outcomes
it's basically never too late to make a
difference and even slow change is still
positive change for future generations
secondly look at how many people are
calling for action on climate issues
groups like friday's for future and
extinction rebellion regardless of how
you feel about their methods are loudly
making climate change an issue and over
the course of two decades have
transformed public priorities on climate
to be clear i'm not saying that as a
society we are currently doing enough to
prevent devastating climate change this
century we're absolutely not what i'm
saying is that people care about the
problem now and specifically care a lot
more than they did relatively recently
the upward trajectory is an incredibly
promising sign and the necessary
precondition to sufficient action and
action is ramping up on an individual
scale with more people changing their
diets and flying less and more
importantly on a governmental scale in
democratic states climate policy is
becoming more ambitious and effective
and to stave off the inevitable comments
in the most important undemocratic state
no not you
china climate policy has been hugely
expanded recently with china now the
world leading producer of electricity
through renewable means of course
however they are still extremely
dependent on coal power and that's
probably not going to change anytime
soon but again
the overall trajectory is positive and
their policies are nothing if not
ambitious it may be late but thanks to
the tireless brave efforts of activists
people around the world are finally
getting the message and that message is
being translated into action and lastly
and most importantly
money money can be exchanged for goods
and services
we may kid ourselves into thinking that
us humans act morally or philosophically
when it comes to big issues like climate
change but historically that's not been
the case the atlantic slave trade and
commercial whaling for example were
morally abhorrent
but ultimately only ceased when they
ceased to be economically viable i know
it was more complicated than that don't
have me i'm making a point that
economics is really important so here's
the good news for a little while now
it's made economic sense to fight
climate change that's partially because
the cost of inaction is now estimated to
be so high higher than any plans are to
combat climate change but more so
because the cost of new renewable
electricity generation is now lower than
the cost of maintaining existing
coal-fired power plants to me this is
the single biggest cause for hope
because there's no morality here there's
no value judgment just cold economic
sense the long arc of history bends
towards economic efficiency and that's
now on the side of reducing carbon
emissions from electricity generation
which combined with the electrification
of other sectors like transport and
heating
we may have just passed the tipping
point in this fight of course you may
have listened to all of this and thought
wow that was a lethal dose of copium but
hear me out perhaps i'm being naive or
optimistic or even in denial about how
serious this problem is but consider the
alternative if we simply give up as i
should stress the science tells us we
shouldn't then what happens as soon as
we lose hope we stop taking action we
consign ourselves to living in a worse
world and we are in a rough situation i
want to be very clear about that but it
is not a situation without hope and the
longer i can keep that hope alive
justifiably at this point the more good
i and by this youtube channel
we
can do so while it may not be easy all
the time i don't give in to climate
despair and neither should you the
trajectory of climate action is upwards
technology and economics are on our side
and any action even if it's not as much
as we scientists would like to see is
still benefiting our descendants we can
still make the changes necessary to
avoid one and a half and two degrees of
warming as a society and i will keep
advocating for those changes
but as i said at the beginning
i'm not hopeful but also
i'm not hopeless
hope is important because it allows us
to imagine a new better future a future
with different better healthcare cities
food even music
this is all the subject of the series
dream the future narrated by sigourney
weaver available on curiositystream who
have kindly sponsored this video
curiosity stream is the number one
source of professional productions on
topics from climate change to natural
history technology to goats they have
thousands of documentaries and shorts
that make you better informed about the
world and make dinner time a place of
learning rather than just re-watching
brooklyn nine-nine again if however you
prefer something a little bit more indie
something with more of a home spun
personal touch then look no further than
nebula the streaming service with a half
a million paying users created by
youtubers like me who wanted
independence from
well youtube nebula is a platform that
we own allowing us total creative
freedom and has a totally different
business model we don't like ads so
nebula has none of them on its pages or
in its videos instead it's a
subscription-based service with your
money funding exclusive original content
like china actually by polymatter as
well as directly supporting the creators
on the platform but why have i told you
about these two services because you can
get both of them in a bundle signing up
at curiositystream.com simon clark you
can get access to curiosity stream and
nebula and get a 26 discount just 14.79
a year for the best documentaries on the
internet and financing exciting new
educational video content online that's
curiositystream.com
simon clark to improve your viewing
experience online and support this
channel
thank you for watching you may have
noticed that you didn't see me at all
this video and that's because pixelgirl
and i are currently between houses we're
living out of boxes for two weeks until
we move into our first home that we own
together hence why no set and no camera
just a microphone and a somewhat slimmed
down script that i hope was still
interesting and in this case maybe even
inspiring next week i'll be putting out
a video to mark this huge life event and
to thank this community for making it
all possible until then there's some
videos you can watch on the screen right
now thank you again for watching and
i'll see you and you'll see me
in the next one